非常重要
因为只要有成交
就代表有人卖出
同时也有人买进
这些买进的人
有很大的部分就是前面提到的
当充买进的人
但是同一时间也是主力最好出货的时机
我们先来科普
什么是主力
什么是出货
主力指的是
当一个投资人大量持有某档股票
而且持有的量多到可以影响这档股票的走势时
这个投资人就足以称作这档股票的主力
但是主力想卖出股票的时候会遇到一个问题
他持有太多了
要有夠多的人願意買他的股票
他才能夠賣出去
因此他會製造一種假象
讓其他人覺得
現在是買進股票的好時機
我們把這種他騙別人買進
自己偷偷賣出的過程
稱為出貨
而兩個低點之間出現區間上下震盪
很可能就是主力製造出來的假象
如果主力直接在下跌的趨勢中
大量賣出股票
但想買的人卻沒有這麼多
股價就會瞬間暴跌
主力自己就賣不到好的價格
所以主力只要制造出股价反弹的假象
在这个区间买进的当充客就会觉得
这里就是低点了
股价开始反弹了
当其他人正在抢着买进股票
主力就默默的把手上的持股
一张一张慢慢的卖出去
所以这个区间的成交量越大代表什么
代表主力出货越顺利
也代表也越多的当充客在这里买进
等到股价真正创新低的耐克才会有足够多的人停损卖出股票成为最强的下跌燃料進一步讓股價跌更深反過來如果這段區間成交量很小代表根本沒有什麼人買進股票
就算之後再創新低
停損賣出的數量也會很少
下跌的力道當然也會比較小
接下來就是這部影片的重點了
既然我們都能提前預支到下跌
那我們就可以透過做空來賺錢
也就是透過先賣後買來當充獲利
但你千萬要注意
我們要賺的是順勢交易
和當沖停損
形成的快速下跌
股價向下沖
通常都是30秒之內的事
等到順勢交易的人都已經進場了
買進的人都停損完了
股價就有可能再次進入上下震盪
運氣不好可能馬上反彈
所以我們要做的事
就是快進快出
當你進場做空後
觀察股價變化的速度
一旦你發現下跌的速度變慢了
就要馬上出場了
如果運氣不好
遇到反彈
反彈的速度
還快到你來不及獲利出場
也請你一定要馬上停損
尤其是股價
如果馬上漲回到原本低點上面
不停損真的會很危險
因為這時候股價會形成一股
強力的上漲訊號
叫做破底翻
你想想股價會反彈一定是有人大量買進
買進的人是誰?
有八成的機率就是主力
主力也知道當股價再次創新低
很多剛剛買的人都會停損
如果他真正的意圖是看漲想買進
那他只要故意讓股價破低
就可以低價買進其他人停損的股票
既然主力現在是看漲
而且正在努力買進股票
那這檔股票就算看起來很弱
也不容易疊